let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony
michaels hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
well happy hump day
it's wednesday
three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern so you know what time that is
it's let's talk time the tony michaels
podcast and boy do we have a ton of
stuff to talk about today
[Music]
afghanistan afghanistan afghanistan they
can't decide if it's good if it's bad if
joe biden's doing good if he [ __ ] it
up or not so we're gonna talk about that
uh it is speaking of afghanistan we have
eric prince apparently charging uh 6 500
for a nice little flight from
kabul to africa when hillary clinton is
charging nothing by the way
and it sounds like airbnb is going to
help
afghan refugees with housing
for free eric prince
really pissed off he can't be a war
profiteer anymore i assume
he's getting that last dip in
before it ends hillary clinton airbnb
it's on the house for them huh
kind of funny
we're also
we're also going to talk about not just
the afghanistan taliban but we're going
to talk about the american taliban y'all
kaida
y'all kaiden there's a ton of al-qaeda
news everybody
uh not just with the proud boys out in
portland and i'm probably not even gonna
get to that today but we had the trump
rally the trump nazi rally the sheep
herding that help happened in coleman
alabama
so we're gonna talk about that and we're
going to get to this select committee
stuff
um because there is a ton
a ton of news dropping this afternoon
about this select committee stuff but i
also i also want to talk about you
al-qaeda on the q anon side um there's a
lot of q anon anti-vaxx anti-mask
um
dewormed de-brained
news
stuff that
we have to get to school board meetings
the like
uh you know the school board
q and on slam poetry
that they've been having
uh
and there's a mayor somewhere in
missouri that i want to talk about too
if i get to it if i get to it but the
first thing i want to do before i get to
any of those subjects is i want to
welcome all the new listeners because
we've been getting more and more new
listeners here and i want to give you an
idea of exactly how this works we go
live
every wednesday three o'clock central
four o'clock eastern
on youtube twitter and twitch
that's where we're at so you can find us
there you can go to thetonymichaels.com
to find all those links uh to the
youtube to the twitter and to the twitch
and then what happens once we get done
recording because it's live
what i do is i take the audio
and i upload it to the interwebs to
apple podcast to spotify to google all
the directories so if you would rather
listen to the podcast as opposed to
watch my ugly face
then you can absolutely go download it
on spotify apple google all your
directories
it's uploaded almost as soon as we're
done here it takes a little bit to get
it uploaded but once we're done
doing the live show then we upload it
for you to download if you want to
listen to it otherwise you can find us
on youtube
you can find us on twitter and you can
find us on twitch i don't know exactly
what twitch is but it's there
whatever it is it's there
and you can always find the videos on
youtube and follow us subscribe on
youtube follow us on twitter
follow on twitch if you're on twitch all
that kind of good stuff but go to
thetonymichaels.com find all those links
there
uh if you're a new listener to find out
what the what the whole shebang is about
now
let's get to this afghanistan thing i
really thought today was going to be a
big show
about afghanistan again well last week
we talked a lot about afghanistan uh you
know it was kind of fresh last week
we've been a week into this there's been
about 90 000 people evacuated total i
think about 82 000 in the last week so
since we're on the show there's just
just over 80 80 000 people that have
been evacuated from afghanistan
and i believe it's under 20 all right
excuse me under 100 000 in total before
and up till now uh
everyone can't decide rather joe biden
[ __ ] this up trump [ __ ] this up who
[ __ ] this up
and and and of course the media can't
get out of the [ __ ] military's way
just to do the evacuation here
joe biden's sticking to his deadline of
august 31st imagine a president making a
decision and [ __ ] sticking to it
sticking to his guns
doing what he says he's gonna do not
taking pressure from someone else
of course uh there's a lot of other
foreign allies that want to extend this
by four days
uh and it looks like they're on pace to
get the people out that they can get out
now
there are going to be people that are
left there that want out
but they've evacuated almost 100
000 people
over 80 000 in the last week get the
[ __ ] out of the military's lane and let
them do their [ __ ] jobs why are
congress people going in there over
there and getting in the way why is the
media i know why the media is bitching
about this they're really upset about
the breakup that they had with the
afghanistan war
they're really they're really [ __ ]
upset
and and you know
the breakup isn't going that well for
them
because if you think about it if you
really think about it what joe biden has
brought brought for us
which it should have been trump it
should have been obama that brought this
to us
was a time of peace in this country
think about it for a second i know it's
hard to imagine for the american people
who haven't been paying attention to the
[ __ ] war we've been in for the last
20 years but
i mean
our voluntary military people the
soldiers the troops
have noticed tour after tour after tour
after tour i'm sure they [ __ ] noticed
the american people not so [ __ ] much
but think about this for a second
in 20 years
20 years this is the first time that we
do not have an act of war
we are in peace time now abroad we are
in peace time because we're going to
talk about the american taliban we're
not at war with the taliban anymore soon
in afghanistan we may be at war with the
american taliban here the al-qaeda
so we're going to talk about that
but as far as abroad we are not
we are in
the dawn
of peace time
and if anyone thinks that joe biden
isn't gonna get the credit for that you
are a [ __ ] bonehead
everyone thinks that joe biden's gonna
pay a big political price here this is a
20-year war
joe biden has been the president for
seven months is he responsible for some
of the decisions that were made
during this process some of the some of
the you know the snags that have
happened of course
but if he gets the blame he gets the
reward too dummy
obama's not going to get credit for
getting us out of afghanistan trump
doesn't want credit
he thinks his deal with the taliban was
[ __ ] horrible i mean they're blaming
it on biden they're blaming the deal
that they made on biden so obviously the
deal that they made with the taliban
wasn't so [ __ ] great
because they keep wanting to push it off
on joe biden
and their base can't decide which side
to be on on afghanistan
they're whining and crying and boohooing
about uh
allies that we may leave there
but they don't want them to come here
they don't want those brown muslim
people here in this country they're
dangerous but they're our allies and we
must save them
they don't even know what they believe
anymore
so we are on
the the dawn of a peace time in this
country and hopefully we can have 20
years of peace where we don't have to go
to [ __ ] war we don't have to send our
our men and women in uniform
time and time and time and time again
for a house of cards
because that's what afghanistan was and
it's obvious now
that it was a house of cards and it's
obvious that the american people were
correct when they were voting for
presidents to get the [ __ ] out of that
place
they were right
the american people were correct
when they were voting
for
presidents to get them out of
afghanistan because again last week i
said this
and it comes on a day where john mccain
it's his anniversary of his one year
anniversary of his death
but john mccain was the last candidate
to run to stay in afghanistan
and my guess is if john mccain was still
alive today he would be bashing biden
and this would all be biden's fault and
you know biden [ __ ] this up and he can't
believe that biden's got
over 90 000 afghanis evacuated like what
are you talking about
how is this not successful
how we're getting out of a war
and we're getting people out of that
country
90 over 90 000 of them and right now
they're probably on planes right now
shove them in counting them up
now
the american government in the military
isn't charging 6 500 hours a pop like
eric prince
i mean you know
maybe that's what they're upset about
so just give it a little bit of time
folks
and we'll see
next week i'm sure i'll be talking about
afghanistan because there will be people
out there can't decide whether it was a
success or a failure the war was a
failure
the war the entire war was a failure
it was that's it
the taliban we didn't get rid of them it
was all a house of cards they always had
control it was all [ __ ] the whole
thing it's obvious it was all [ __ ]
the whole time
maybe that way you know
certain people could put money in their
pockets
i'm sure that's what was going on
so we're getting out of a war
in afghanistan with the afghani
taliban
but here at home
we seem to be in a war
with the american taliban the al-qaeda
proud boys oath keepers q anon maga
the trump humpers
evangelical christians you know
at one point in this country
the crazy
didn't seem like there was as much of it
and i think the reason why is because it
was all you know they all had their own
little thing going on right their own
little crazy
you know
you had the flat earthers
you had the anti-baxters
you had all this crazy running around
you know
the the chemtrail info war nut jobs
and all this crazy but they weren't all
gathered up in one [ __ ] spot
but this weekend
holy [ __ ] this weekend they gathered up
in one goddamn spot
in coleman alabama
pew pew pew pew yeehaw
and it rained on him
soggy sheep stench
was the uh the fragrance coming out of
coleman alabama you know
i know you guys like the uh the tick
tock walking rants that i do
and i did one uh for this specific thing
and we got a lot of video i'd like to
play today so hopefully we get
to a lot of this video but with some of
the news coming out about the select
committee and the the the generals of
the al qaeda uh all the members of
congress the generals the al-qaeda
generals that's maybe what i'll deem
them now is the al-qaeda generals that
way you guys know when i'm tweeting and
i'm talking about the congress people
who were seditious and trying to help
trump with his cheeto dust kangaroo coup
they were the al qaeda generals that's
what we'll refer to him as i like that i
like that we'll go with that but let's
watch the video
about coleman alabama because i think
this is really
it was like a wet fart and a white thong
it did not go well it did not go well
it for trump for their supporters it
looked horrible it was a lot of bad
imagery
and
i'll show you the video dewormed or
de-brained let's talk the maga variant
stupid virus is spreading like wildfire
around the country and the trumpets are
pouring gasoline all over it last night
grandpa poopy pants herded up his sheep
in a remote pasture in coleman alabama
you know the home of those sun downtown
non-racist type white people
they weren't allowed to bring in guns
selfie sticks or toasters for safety but
they all seemed to get a full dose of
the horse d wormer ivermectin at the
gate so there's that next thing you know
these [ __ ] spread necks will be
wearing flea and tick collars to stave
off the rona maybe we should consider a
yall kaida national spay and neuter
program jesus [ __ ] christ best parts
of the whole show is when mo brooks
couldn't pack the big lie back in
pandora's box and the cheeto dust
mobster got booed for promoting the
vaccine maybe you [ __ ] eaters should
stick to your culty feed store medical
advice
[ __ ] them
so i really took the slant of the
ivermectin horse dewormer feed store
medical
uh advice that these people have been
running around the country talking about
this is this is getting really
ridiculous i seen a tweet
uh
it's very close to home it's here in
missouri it's at the lake of the ozarks
hey are you guys familiar with the uh
the series netflix on netflix called
ozark
that uh with jason bateman uh ozark that
is about
uh a town in missouri and the town is
osage beach and lake ozark and if you're
not from missouri or don't know the area
very well lake ozark and osage beach are
kind of one and the same anymore
it's called the lake of the ozarks and
it's the that certain side of the lake
there's there's two sides of the lake
and that's that the saint louis side of
the lake is osage beach and lake ozark
and lake ozark is where bagnal dam is
that's what creates lake of the ozarks
and there's all kinds of stuff at the
lake to do of course boating and fishing
and you know when you have a city you
have to elect a mayor
and the great
great citizens of lake ozark decided to
elect a mayor and he's a realtor
um
hey at the lake of the ozarks in lake
ozark
and
this guy tweets out or put i don't know
where the i don't know you put it on
facebook i don't know where the [ __ ]
this guy posted it
he really really
makes
the
series ozark look like it's very
dead on accurate
because this guy tweets out that his
best friend
is in the hospital
of with kovid
and he's obscured some ivormectin he he
puts in quotes ivermectin it's a horse
dewormer i don't know
it could have been because he said
ivermectin it's it's tough because if
you do a little bit of your own research
there you cue an honors if you go do
your own research
ivermectins and things like uh flea and
tick collars
uh it's in in front line you guys know
frontline not i mean not maybe not
specifically frontline but you know that
product that you put on your pets so
they don't get uh
uh fleas and ticks you put it on the
back of the nape of their neck
ivermectin is in that
that's because ivormectin is a [ __ ]
pesticide it's to kill parasites
you know
t
fleas ticks
worms
and the stuff that they're getting
apparently at the feed store is dosed
for cattle and horses
um but the mayor the elected mayor i'm
not [ __ ] you i'm not [ __ ] you
the elected mayor of lake ozark this guy
this guy got [ __ ] people to vote for
him to run he runs [ __ ] he's in charge
of stuff
he's a [ __ ] charge of stuff
this guy goes to the feed store gets
horse dewormer i'm assuming ivermectin
and he's gonna take it to the hospital
to give it to his friend who is
hospitalized for covid and in in the in
the post
he says i'm hoping that the hospital
will stand aside and let me administer
the poison on my friend now he didn't
say poison
but that's that's what it is it's it's
it's poison it kills
parasites
it's
poison
ah
you just you just you just cannot make
this [ __ ] up
you can't make this [ __ ] up i mean i
mean
the crazy is [ __ ] everywhere
it's [ __ ] everywhere and it's all
part of this proud boy oath keeper trump
humping
evangelical christian q anon stuff
i mean we got people showing up at
[ __ ] school board meetings talking
about snipers and
and and and carrying on about the the
blood sucking cabal and and how the
schools are gonna be turned in
concentration camps did you guys see
this video there's a lady that shows up
i think it was in greenville south
carolina shows up at a school board
meeting stands in front of a microphone
why the [ __ ] they left this lady in
front of a microphone i have no idea
she's standing in front of a microphone
talking about how they're gonna turn
schools into concentration camps the cdc
not the school board the cdc is gonna do
this
i think it's clear to me now
why we have such [ __ ] stupid people
in this country
and the reason why is because
this is the reason why they don't like
democracy because they don't even know
what the [ __ ] it is
people
in most places
in this country
school board members the school board
council the people that make the
decisions for the policy of the school
board who to hire the administrators you
know if they step in fire people you
know running running the school district
is what the school board does these are
elected officials
they're elected okay they're not
appointed by
joe biden
joe biden and the cdc did not appoint
these people you elected him well i mean
you probably didn't vote because you're
too [ __ ] boneheaded to even realize
that the school board is elected
officials that if you don't like the
ones you have now you go vote against
for someone else or run yourself
and then that's the fear that i have is
we get a bunch of q and honors on these
school boards these [ __ ] knuckleheads
knuckle dragon boneheads
but they're elected officials people
they're not they're not
[ __ ] ss officers
they are elected
and the claim is is that the cdc is
going to turn school into concentration
camps that's what they're claiming
so your thought process is
the school board is mandating mask to
make sure that they can have kids in
school
but you want to not have masks in school
because concentration camps are
happening but the reason why that the
school board wants to have the mask is
so that
we don't get
dozens and dozens of children sick and
you have to call off school like
literally the reason why the school
boards want to have the mask mandate is
to make sure that they have school
not the other way around it's not to not
have school it's to have school like
that's what the masks are designed to do
is to make it possible so people don't
get sick so they can have school schools
call a school
school district calls school off all the
time for the flu when it's when the flu
gets rampant in a school and they're
spreading it around which now we know
mass can help that they should
when the flu is going around in school
they should do a mask mandate have
everyone in their
knock out the flu it's it's pretty
pretty good mitigation tactic it works
pretty well
but these people think
that the reason why the school want to
have masks
is to keep the kids in school
so they can have concentration camps and
it's exactly
like they they
we're not turn what the [ __ ] are you
people where
get off facebook get the [ __ ]
off facebook stop stop
just stop scrolling down face it's not
even worth it anymore don't scroll down
facebook don't do it go to [ __ ] go back
to pinterest
go look up your your crock pot crock pot
recipes on pinterest get the [ __ ] off
facebook karen
you queueing on manga trump hump and
fool
[ __ ] people are boneheaded just
[ __ ] boneheaded and then you have
these governors and attorney state
attorney generals trying to prevent
local government
school boards which is local government
they're elected officials they govern
the [ __ ] public school district it's
a local government entity
republican conservative
conservative small government
republicans
we don't like local government anymore
and the reason why we don't like local
government is
because
well
they believe in science and stuff
what the [ __ ] is going on in missouri
the attorney general is suing the school
board
in colombia because they're having a
mass mandate and he's hoping he's hoping
that when he wins all the other mass
mandates in the state will have to go
away well he's going to lose that
[ __ ] battle
he's going to lose
he knows he's going to lose
the only reason why this [ __ ]
bonehead is doing this in the first
place
is for the fans i've talked about this
before on here it's all for the fans
it's for that stupid karen that's
standing in front of the microphone at
the school board meeting
it's for them
it's for them to keep them going to the
school board meeting
and causing chaos because
folks
they can't win without chaos
they can't win without chaos they can't
they won't
speaking of winning
politicians winning
and the american taliban and al qaeda
and queueing on
there's a lot of stuff happening in
congress right now a lot of stuff
a lot of stuff
yesterday
the house democrats passed and i say
democrats because not one [ __ ]
republican
voted for investment in infrastructure
in the united states of america kevin
mccarthy believes that the
infrastructure bill all that money is
going to go to afghanistan i don't know
what he thinks i don't i don't know if
he knows where afghanistan is at he
might think it's a [ __ ] state in the
united states
the infrastructure bill
the investment into the infrastructure
the united states of america
three and a half trillion dollars
which joe biden's gonna get credit for
the democrats are going to get credit
for because not one goddamn republican
voted for it
got passed
and nancy pelosi the gqp kryptonite made
sure of it
she made sure of it
and slam dunk kevin mccarthy in the
trash
in the [ __ ] trish
they also passed hr4 which is another
voting rights bill in the name of john
lewis
so they're putting more pressure on
cinema
and mansion to pass it in the senate
which is good so there's a lot of stuff
going on in congress a lot of wheels
turning
a lot of wheel start see
what happens is
when you are a responsible politician
and you're good at policy and you're
good at you know like walking and
chewing gum at the same [ __ ] time
kevin mccarthy you can actually you
could actually focus on two or three
things at once you can do that it is
possible
i mean i know you have difficulty
other than focusing on your cheeto dust
knee pads
and how to put them on and make sure and
they're on all the time
but
most reasonable people especially
democrats
are able to
you know multitask
think about afghanistan
and pass infrastructure pass
infrastructure and figure out why the
[ __ ] you idiots are trying to rig up
elections with voter suppression in the
states
like most you know intelligent human
beings can do a couple things at once
you [ __ ] can't
so
kevin mccarthy
is very concerned
very
very very and he looks concerned did you
see the video
of him being asked questions about
whether he's going to preserve his
documents
because this is this is a great story
this is a story we're going to be
talking about next week i know it
i know it
i know this story is going to evolve
where next week this is going to be the
big the big part of the show here
is a select committee has dropped
their first document request
now i don't think they're official
subpoenas it doesn't appear to be
official subpoenas yet but they're
telling everybody
hey
all those documents you got on your
cheeto dust kangaroo coup
you might want to hang on to those we're
gonna need them and they're requesting
them from people like
mark meadows
uh he was the chief of staff of somebody
i think during that time of january 6. i
can't remember who it's really hard to
tell
rudy giuliani which was a lawyer to the
cheeto dust mobster
steve bannon steve bannon isn't even
he isn't even like part of the
administration at that point him and
roger stone now there's been a little
feuding going on with them i wonder if
this has anything to do with it
the other thing is all well not all but
you know
the ones that are out there yelling and
screaming the trump children
ivanka
don jr
eric
jared kushner
the documents they're saying save those
[ __ ] the other significant one
is sydney powell
you know the kraken so maybe
maybe just maybe with these documents we
will finally release the kraken
but the select committee is going to get
to these documents
and why this is very important is
because
they need to find out who when what
where and why
and if congress people had anything to
do with the seditious act of january 6
which my guess is that there is
and i even did a video about it that's
right did a video uh let's see here
where where is it at
uh oh yes there it is it's about the
cheeto dust kangaroo coup hmm have you
ever noticed that republican congressman
tried to help grandpa poopypants
overthrow the united states constitution
with his cheeto dust kangaroo coup
i'm talking to you mo brooks and jim i
don't report sex crimes jordan you've
squeezed up treasonous [ __ ]
[ __ ] them
so kevin mccarthy seems very very very
concerned about january 6 so much so of
the select committee getting documents
for january 6 so much so that he's
willing to stand in front of a
microphone in the camera and talk about
oh i've already i've already told the
american public what i know about that
day there's nothing else to know trust
me i've already disclosed it i did three
interviews three of them on three
different networks so that's all there
is to know i definitely have not
anything to hide
okay
okay now it's becoming more and more
clear why kevin mccarthy mitch mcconnell
and all the republicans didn't want the
january six uh uh commission the
original one you know the 911 style one
you remember that one you remember the
911 style commission
they passed it in the house it went to
the senate the senate slam dunked it
because they they didn't want anything
to do with that
they did not want their [ __ ] phone
records out there their text messages
their emails their communications with
oath keepers their communications with
the proud boys with steve bannon i'm
sure with roger stone the trump children
mark meadows
i'm talking to you mo brooks and jim
jordan i'm sure you're gonna be
subpoenaed that's why that's why
that is why nancy pelosi did not let jim
jordan on to the january select
committee in the house it's because jim
jordan is a material witness he's gonna
be subpoenaed
he's gonna be subpoenaed probably more
than likely i'm sure that's what's gonna
happen that's why they're [ __ ]
terrified they were terrified of the 911
style commission that they wanted
couldn't do that
you know potato tomato remember this
remember this potato tomato
potato tomato video i made
about al oh well
they're they're tourists
remember they went on and on about this
ah they they weren't it wasn't an
insurrection no need to look into it it
wasn't an insurrection even though kevin
mccarthy says today that the fbi already
did their investigation and the fbi says
it's an insurrection nope nope it was an
interaction it was just plain old
good-hearted white cracker tourism
not terrorism tourism they were taking a
tour of the capital
well
i remember
i remember and the reason why i remember
is because i did a video about it
tourism terrorism potato tomato let's
talk make traders kevin mccarthy and
moscow mitch mcconnell do not want a
commission looking into the january 6th
treasonous insurrection hmm i wonder why
it'd be that them and some of their
members were trying to overthrow the
government of the united states yeah no
[ __ ] sherlock we're gonna let the
seditious traders vote on whether we
should investigate them or not jesus
[ __ ] christ don't like this 911 style
commission [ __ ] that's because they're
the [ __ ] terrorists just think about
it wouldn't been [ __ ] swell if the
911 terrorists got to vote not to be
investigated jesus would have been even
better if they would have had a
propaganda cable news show called
schmucker carlson or some [ __ ] like that
how to spread the fear and their
terrorist lies around believe your eyes
it was just a regular plane ride on a
tour of the world trade centers connor
mccarthy and all you trees and his manga
trump bumpers in congress go munch on a
big bag of horse dicks [ __ ] them
it's kind of interesting how we come
full circle here when i i talk about a
911 style commission and how
the terrorists would have loved not to
be to decide if they were going to be
investigated or not for the terrorism
that they brought on this country on 9
11 when they flew the planes into the
world trade center
that oh it was it wasn't terrorism it
was just a tour of the world train
center you know with via plane
and here we are today talking about the
exit of the afghanistan war 20 years
later and the american taliban y'all
kaidah
because that's what this is folks that's
what they the select committee is going
to overturn that's why kevin mccarthy
looks like he's going to [ __ ] his pants
when he's asked questions about if his
records are gonna be subpoenaed
and if he's gonna you know hold on to
those records don't be using the [ __ ]
paper shredder
kevin
i'm telling you
this january select committee and i know
it's a drip drip trip and a slow process
but we've also got reports that
these people did the amount of video the
amount of video evidence from january 6
i think someone said the amount that it
would be almost take you almost 500 days
for one person to watch it
and there ain't no telling how many
communications not just a text message
phone call but social media post who god
who knows the the mountain
the mountain that these these
investigators are trying to have to go
through
to figure out who who colluded with who
in this seditious act of january 6th
but there were
it was organized it was [ __ ]
organized
and you're starting to see who it was
organized by and the reason why is
because the select committee is
going to request the documents of the
people who they think
there's evidence of
who is organizing it
and it all leads back to one
[ __ ] spot all of it
all of it
the whole [ __ ] and that is the
cheeto dust mobster because this is a
cult folks it's a cult
it's a [ __ ] cult cult 45
oh well that cues another one pope 45
let's talk cheeto dust ball sec hangs
hard on the gqp as the january 6 select
committee commences today with the us
capitol police officer's testimony it
sure does not seem like blue lives
matter
you know the non-white kind their
witness statements they call the
insurrection a treasonous coup attempt
because that's what the [ __ ] it is why
do you think the treasonous republicans
don't want the american people to hear
the truth about their mussolini jesus
with fascists truth is the enemy and the
khan is a cult it's a [ __ ] cult hey
you timothy mctrump humping traders the
truth is it was a [ __ ] cheeto dust
coup attempt pluck your head out of your
[ __ ] asses [ __ ] them
and that
is why the summation of why kevin
mccarthy and the republicans didn't want
the 911 style commission
they definitely don't want this select
committee that is
basically controlled by nancy pelosi can
nancy nancy pelosi is the gqp kryptonite
and she's gonna slam dunk these
[ __ ] in the garbage
they are completely [ __ ] here kevin
mccarthy you are never going to be the
speaker of the house never
you're not going to be you
today would be a good day for you to
retire
today would be
i mean tomorrow but today would be a
better day
you may need it you may need the time to
straight scrape together all your phone
records that the select committee's
gonna need
because this all leads back to one
[ __ ] that's that that's one
person one reason
the whole reason why we talk about this
the whole reason why there's a select
committee the whole reason why there was
a [ __ ] january 6 is because the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy pants
the the mango mussolini jesus
just couldn't
come to grips with losing
so he had to create the big lie
he had to
he had to he had to you know create this
big lie and the other thing too is he
had to stab off all these federal
investigations into him his kids his
businesses his inaugural committee
all these you know the congressional
uh uh uh they're trying to get his tag
the congressional committee trying to
get his taxes he was trying to stave
that off and the only way to really keep
this all at bay is to remain president
and i think i think this [ __ ] really
thought he was going to win i think he
really thought that this country loved
him
and i think that's the biggest fraud
that has been wrought on us this entire
[ __ ] time is somehow he has this big
huge base
because at the rally at the rally in
coleman alabama
the the sheep herding contest that they
had
down in coleman
it's the same [ __ ]
that are behind him if you look at the
crowd behind him it's the same
[ __ ] it's been the same
[ __ ] for a long time
they fly those [ __ ] in put them
up behind them like props
same [ __ ]
same [ __ ] sheep
same costumes same everything
and it was it was really great
speaking of the trump rally it was
really great to watch him
advocate for the vaccine which you know
we should give him credit that he was
trying but
when he started when he started to tell
these people that yeah you should go get
vaccine they turned on him and he could
sense it and he's like oh [ __ ] no no
freedom freedom freedom
hey he he backed away from it really
[ __ ] fast like really fast
and mo brooks he had trouble too because
he was like no forget about the whole
coup thing
forget about the whole koo thing
let's let's do a coup in 22.
hey that's a good campaign
this needs to trend
someone get out there i know you're
listening to me on twitter get out there
cool and 22. that's gonna be their
campaign slogan
i'm sure trump will run around all over
the country we can call it coo and 22.
that's what they want they want a coup
in 22. they want to take back the house
because donald trump isn't going to
ascend to the presidency until september
89th or sometime before the first of the
year
and if that
this is all [ __ ] i can't even believe
these people believe this [ __ ] if that
doesn't happen then then they're going
to win that at the house in the coup of
22
and when they win the house in kua 22
they're going to anoint their mango
mussolini jesus the cheeto dust mobster
grandpa poopypants they're going to
anoint him
speaker of the house
and he's going to
uh impeach joe biden and remove him i
guess you know with a an executive order
from the speaker or
i don't know
i don't know what the [ __ ] they think
it's all [ __ ] boneheaded it's all
convoluted because folks the politics of
it is
is here's the thing
joe biden put is putting money in your
[ __ ] account every month
with with the coronavirus package that
they passed
with the stimulus and now with the child
tax credit anyone who have children out
there they're getting that are under 18
or under they're getting money flushed
into their account every month i haven't
heard one [ __ ] [ __ ] about that
socialism not one [ __ ] not one
not one and they're not going to
when all these communities
start to see this uh over four billion
dollars in infrastructure but between
the 1.1 trillion and the 3.5 trillion
that they passed whatever whatever mix
they get together here and reconcile
and pass and joe biden signs whatever
that infrastructure looks like they're
gonna see all those investments coming
in their communities
because let's face it folks our highways
suck our internet sucks
and not just that we could we could use
a hell of a lot better medical and
hospital infrastructure it is clear that
we do not we do not have our [ __ ] act
together in this country
especially in parts of the country that
aren't able to handle a pandemic
rather they're bone-headed and not to to
listen to doctors and nurses and get a
vaccine but they are not prepared
so the politics of the coronavirus
package the politics of the
infrastructure package the politics of
getting us out of the afghanistan war
and the politics of giving you more
access to the ballot box if they do get
voting rights passed which i am going to
say right here right now i believe that
there is going to be a bill on joe
biden's desk before the end of the year
that has something to do with voting
rights now rather it's this is hr one
it's the john lewis voting rights act of
this new hr four
yeah that's a you know for the people
act this john lewis the other john lewis
there's going to be a bill on joe
biden's desk that he's going to sign
before the end of the year and the
reason why is because democrats aren't
letting these [ __ ] republicans get in
their way of doing their work
they're not letting the noise get in
their way
they're not and they're not going to and
the reason why is because they're
concerned about policy
not theatrics not the fans
the trump mania fans they're not worried
about that [ __ ]
they're worried about what the american
people want and joe biden knows that the
american people want infrastructure
joe biden knows that people wanted to
[ __ ] fix the coronavirus
joe biden knows that the [ __ ] country
wants out of the afghanistan war and
they want access to the goddamn ballot
so they have the actual right to vote
everywhere it doesn't matter what
[ __ ] state you got the right to vote
and it's secured and guaranteed the way
that you need to vote
you get to decide
that's what scares them to death about
all of it
is that not only are they going to be
held accountable for the cheeto dust
kangaroo coup
but they're terrified that they will not
be able they will not be able to commit
another another coup
cooin 22
is very very bad if joe biden gets
infrastructure
cooing 22 is very very very bad if joe
biden gets credit for getting us out of
afghanistan
[ __ ] 22
is really really really [ __ ] bad
if joe biden secures voting rights in
this country
and it turns back the clock on all these
these voter suppression laws that these
republicans are trying to pass in these
red states
that's why they want to keep coronavirus
going that's why they don't want people
to get vaccine that's why they want
people to poison themselves
with feed store medical advice
is to keep the the trumpism going the
trump of mania going because let's be
frank about it
if we didn't have these anti-maskers
anti-baxters
because all of a sudden these right-wing
groups like the the proud boys and oath
keepers and
all these people these q and honors
they've all turned into anti-baxters
anti-masters and that's the trumpism now
you know that that's where they live
that's where they live
again they used to be all separated out
right and the crazy you know we had
we had a low dose of crazy at any given
moment but now they're all [ __ ]
gathered up in one goddamn spot
so the crazy seems like it's everywhere
and it's dumped on us and dumped on us
and dumped on us
but that that will not last
i'm telling you it won't last
more and more people are getting
vaccinated
more and more
today
delta airlines
announced that they are going to
charge more for people who are not
vaccinated
for the for the insurance that they get
through their company
more and more companies are requiring
some sort of requirement
uh joe biden the federal government says
hey if you get federal money
if you get federal money you
have to have your employees vaccinated
in a nursing home
if you
are in a long-term care facility
if you own one run one work in one and
you want to receive federal dollars
you must
be vaccinated you have to do that thing
that's a big one the united states
military
guess what
now that the vaccine is fully approved
by the fda the pentagon says you gotta
get vaccinated
jerry jones of the cowboys
the dallas cowboys jerry jones you know
i'm talking about
even this motherfucker's like all right
enough's enough
i've heard enough
you people taking horse dewormer is
enough
he took one look at these [ __ ] spread
necks taking horse dewormer and he's
like ah go get vaccinated go go it's not
it's not about you it's about we and the
reason why jerry jones is concerned
about people getting vaccinated is
because it's going to affect his
pocketbook they don't want the nfl shut
down again they don't want that
they want to keep it open you know keep
that that atm machine stuffing money in
their pockets
that's what was going to happen here in
the first place well goddamn that's why
walmart and hogan and
and and and all these companies
all these companies have decided to to
require vaccines and it's going to get
more and more and more and it's the
schools are going to require it for
teachers uh eventually students will
have to have it they're already haven't
had it for most colleges
you boneheads out there thinking that
you're not going to get vaccinated well
you're just gonna go sit at home
you're gonna have to stay at home
program
because that's your choice your body
your choice
you will choose not to do [ __ ] not to
have a job not to go to a football game
not to get on a plane you ain't gonna be
able to do [ __ ]
and that's your choice
i hope you're willing to live with your
great choices that you have in this
country because you have the freedom to
make the choice
you have the freedom to make the choice
it's going to be fantastic trust me it's
going to be great
so
i'm glad you joined me today we have
about 13 13 12 13 minutes left and i
want to remind everyone again
of how this works the new listeners here
and the reason why is because we're
getting more and more new listeners so i
want to thank you guys out there
for sharing the clips on twitter
watching the tick tocks
we have a new a brand new twitter page
uh tony michael's pod it's the podcast
just search tony michael's podcast
you'll find it or go to my at the tony
michaels and and the link is there
we have a brand new twitter page just
for the podcast we'll be posting clips
on there uh when we post a youtube video
we'll be putting updates there for
youtube videos that go up so you'll be
able to find everything there
it just makes it a little more less
clunky because i've been tweeting a lot
lately there's a lot going on so i don't
want the podcast stuff to fall out of
the mix so we've created a new twitter
account so go over there and follow that
account but we do this show live it's
live i'm live right now
no not scripted not edited
and we go live every wednesday three
o'clock central four o'clock eastern
we're on youtube
which is one of the easiest ways to find
us
so go subscribe to that channel we're on
twitter so we stream live on twitter and
there's some people out there watching
us on twitter right now we also stream
on twitch i have no idea i thought
twitch was a gaming thing
i thought this is what it was
and and apparently the videos don't stay
there or something i don't know i'm i
don't know much about twitch but we are
streaming there so if you like to listen
to things on twitch
go over to twitch you can watch the
podcast there and i think it saves the
last two weeks worth of podcast so
normally there's two or three and the
reason why i say two or three is because
we're doing special guest episodes
so we do the live show on wednesdays and
you guys know that i've had guests on
here before but we're gonna switch gears
a little bit with guests because
sometimes it's hard for a guest to get
right at the exact time that we need to
go live so if you guys didn't watch it
we did a special guest episode with
jimmy kennedy uh he's the executive
producer of no casler's podcast
he came on the show and we actually
aired that live it was a recorded
episode but we aired it live on a friday
at three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern so i think the more guest
episodes that we get maybe we'll we'll
pick out friday and do it at the same
time if that continues to work we'll
continue to do it so watch for those
episodes too
but all the episodes all of them
and i believe this this is episode 34.
so all of the episodes you can download
on spotify apple product apple podcast
all your directories all of them now
there are a few
uh podcasts missing on youtube i did
have a few band they pulled them down
they won't you know yeah you know you
know and that's how it goes
cancel culture
but you can find all of them
all of them on your podcast directories
if you want to listen to them if you
don't want to you know see my pretty
face
you just want to hear my beautiful voice
then you can go listen to them on apple
podcast spotify all your directories
but i really do appreciate you guys
coming here and being here uh i i hope
that we can
continue the special guest episodes
we're gonna go live every wednesday
every single wednesday
and if you do like the podcast because i
appreciate all the support all the
shares all the retweets all the comments
all the follows subscribing i love all
of it
but if you want to support the podcast
there are subscription fees that we have
to have there's publication fees that we
have to have to keep this going
you can go to thetonymichaels.com
we've got the merch store we also have
hats i'm gonna get my red and blue hats
up there i promise
promise and i'll do an announcement as
soon as we get the red and blue hats
on the store fully loaded i'll do an
announcement but go check that stuff out
you can get you a [ __ ] sticker here's
a there's a fuck-up sticker so if you
want to support the store uh monetarily
for like subscription fees the
publication fees that go along with
keeping it published so you guys can go
download it and download it and download
and download it you can do that too
i really appreciate all you guys out
there following me i appreciate you
commenting watching the show keep
watching stay tuned because i'm sure
next week
i'm almost betting next week
that there's going to be certain
characters that we're going to be
talking about i'm sure uh one of those
characters will probably be uh mark
meadows and rudy giuliani
because rudy's in a lot of big trouble
here uh with these documents with
january 6 because he's got a lot of
other trouble in federal court so i
would imagine that rudy giuliani is
going to be a hot topic next week and
mark meadows as well because mark metals
was right there with the cheeto dust
mobster
right there with the cheeto dust mobster
uh the other the other people that i
think
that are gonna be hot topics next week
is joe biden and afghanistan we're going
to have a lot clearer vision of what the
evacuation and the the finalizing and
evacuation how many people were actually
evacuated out of afghanistan how that is
going to roll down because
he is not changing the deadline of g of
august 31st he is not changing that
deadline he's already said he's not
going to change it he told the world
leaders he's not going to change it i
think they wanted four extra days i
don't know if anyone's out there but i
think there's four extra days is what
they wanted is with the report that i
read
uh he did he's not going to give that to
him he's not he's not budging august
31st is the deadline so we will know
next week a little more about what the
exit of afghanistan actually looks like
the finalizing of it
that deadline
so i'm sure we'll talk a little bit
about that
but i think this select committee is
going to be huge in the news next week
uh as as these requests for these
documents come in
that's going to be the thing to watch
that's the show to watch
that's it
the select committee nancy pelosi is
gonna eat kevin mccarthy's lunch
you know
i'm not always
a fan
of nancy pelosi but she really truly is
the gqp kryptonite
i mean
she just absolutely makes these people
melt like [ __ ] ice cream cones
they can't eat they they can't even
manage
can't even manage
with her in charge
so
maybe give a shout out to speaker that's
right kevin mccarthy speaker pelosi
because
she's your daddy
and until next time till next time we
got a little more time but we're gonna
cut it short today
until next week
[ __ ] em